[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
who wouldn't move Ted Cruz
[Music]
I mean this should be like a national
type anthem
Ted Cruz shows up you [ __ ] boo him
that is how it works let's talk about
our democracy for a minute
but let's do it
well the song was gonna play again why
not why not play the song again
Ted Cruz gets booed at a Yankee game of
course he does why wouldn't Ted Cruz get
booed to the Yankees game and why I
guess the better question is why the
hell would Ted Cruz go to a Yankees game
other than his Astros played but really
if Ted Cruz cared about his Astros
playing at Yankee Stadium maybe I don't
know he should stick around through the
stretch
uh you fake ass [ __ ]
it was all fake Ted Cruz is Faker than
[ __ ] Donald Trump
but let me tell you something
no matter how bad of a weekend you had I
mean it could have been the worst
weekend ever if you woke up this morning
with the videos of Ted Cruz getting
booed you felt you felt like a million
bucks you felt like a million [ __ ]
bucks
how many people are there that like Ted
Cruz that's a good question I don't know
that's probably an that's probably the
where you need to go
with this situation
ah eat [ __ ] Ted Cruz I think I'm gonna
make a t-shirt what do you guys think
what do you want you want to you want to
eat [ __ ] Ted Cruz t-shirt I think that's
what we're gonna do
we are going to make eat [ __ ] Ted Cruz
hoodies shirts sweaters hell we might
even make some [ __ ] hats [ __ ] them
Ted Cruz you piece of [ __ ] now there's
important news in Texas other than Ted
Cruz getting [ __ ] booed out of Yankee
Stadium there's important news in Texas
right now early voting is open in Texas
people are voting right now as we speak
as they should be they should be leaning
into democracy they should be making
sure that they're casting their ballot
now and making sure their friends their
family and their Community cast their
ballots now is the time it's early
voting I have some video today also from
Mesa Arizona this is [ __ ] fantastic
folks I don't know I'm not sure exactly
who this Patriot is
but this person goes to challenge these
uh these domestic terrorists who are
doing ballot Dropbox intimidation
um and she challenges them the same way
they're challenging people legally
dropping their ballots in drop boxes and
they [ __ ] scary they they scatter
like [ __ ] cockroaches that they are
now we have that video today that I'm
going to show you that's very important
now today also another piece of news
it's Monday and boy we got more [ __ ]
news
like it's been two weeks already
it's been it's been a long year already
this morning
um this this afternoon at 1 30 p.m
Eastern which um will be the bottom of
our second hour the Department of
Justice is supposed to have a press
conference
um there's going to be the FBI director
the attorney general and the deputy
attorney general apparently are going to
be talking about a state actor
um this mean a nation-state actor which
means they're going to be talking about
a country trying to do something here
um my assumption is this is going to
have to do with the election in Russia
they probably have evidence that Russia
is actively trying to interfere in our
election and they're probably going to
warn the American people here's to what
to look for
um and and anyone in a manga hat you
probably should assume or standing
intimidating people at ballot drop boxes
pretty much assume they're domestic
terrorists and they're working in the
interest of Putin that's probably I I
mean I'm just guessing again I I'm only
going on assumption based on what the
statements are this morning but we will
cover that I'm hoping that they do it
promptly they probably won't it is the
Department of Justice
um so we'll try to stay with that
through the show so today's show may be
a little long if you're out there
listening just for that fact
that the Department of Justice is going
to hold a press conference and again
they're not really saying anything but
it's about a nation-state actor which is
a country a lot of people were confused
about that this morning of what that
meant I don't believe this is going to
have anything to do with the documents
case against Trump speaking of trump and
Trump organization uh the accountability
criminal trial I don't know if fake
games back in the chat yet but the
criminal trial starts today fake game
it starts today fake game has always
said there's no criminal charges against
Trump there is criminal charges against
Trump folks and today starts the first
trial of the Trump organization the
company that he owns and runs is under
criminal trial today it starts today
um I'm sure we won't get news out of it
until tomorrow now speaking of more
criminal trials uh Stuart Rhodes the
founder of The Oath Keepers apparently
he is not able to attend his trial today
they had to recess because he has
coveted I noticed someone in the in the
uh in the thread on Twitter said my
condolences
to covid and I feel the same way so
Stuart Rose will not be
um on trial today because of covet his
attorneys actually are trying to get the
court to proceed without Stewart Rhodes
present
um the problem is is that the jail where
he's being housed because he's in
isolation because he's tested positive
for coven will not allow his attorneys
to meet with him face to face at this
point so they recessed until tomorrow
and apparently they're going to try to
figure it out as to how they're going to
proceed because apparently they want
some Secret Service witnesses to take
the stand they don't they don't find it
necessary that Stewart has to be in the
courtroom I don't know why they can't
video in him in you know like give him
audio and video feed of what's going on
maybe they'll do that and and maybe he
won't agree to that you know I I don't
know
um so we'll find out exactly how that
federal trial will proceed uh
as that goes on so we'll see when what
the news comes out of that but I think
it's very significant in a day like
today when we have Federal trials going
on for seditious conspiracy conspiracies
even though they're delayed by covid I
think it's very interesting today that
the Trump organization and Trump himself
the head of that organization is on
trial because he owns it
he owns that organization okay Donald
Trump owns that organization and he is
on trial in the state of New York for
crimes that his
company that he owns that he directed
did Alan weiselberg will be testifying
against the Trump organization
I find it interesting that Alan
weiselberg pleads guilty the CFO
basically second in charge the Chief
Financial Officer of trump organization
pleads guilty the judge tells him you
will cooperate with the prosecutors in
the prosecution of the Trump
organization only and I I don't know why
this is not like everywhere this should
be at the top of the list on Twitter
that Trump is on criminal trial right
now as we speak I know it doesn't feel
like it because he's not personally on
trial
I get it I get that that it doesn't feel
like that is Justice well let me tell
you something about what is going to
happen in New York when the state of New
York absolutely [ __ ] crushes Trump
organization uh Tish James as well and
next week is going to have a hearing on
making sure this [ __ ] isn't
moving assets because they are
attempting it appears to open up a
Delaware organization called Trump org
too
to move assets from Trump org to this
Delaware Corporation to try to make sure
that they still have their money
laundering machine
let me tell you something
because a lot of people last week were
really upset about Steve Bannon only
getting four months and then the judge
let Steve Bannon out on appeal
and I told you last week that Steve
Bannon will serve every single day of
that Federal sentence every day of it
now he's going to get credit
for the day that he was arraigned and
arrested that is very important here he
will get credit but he will serve every
single day
because let me tell you if his if his
appeal
is as flimsy as his defense he will not
win his appeal
appeal is a much higher bar
than just a defense and a trial and the
reason why is because you're already
convicted
now the reason why I know these things
the reason why I know Steve Bannon will
serve every single day and I want you to
be rest assured that he will serve every
single day of that four months
eventually
is that I know because I've been in the
Federal Criminal Justice System
I've been there I've done that before I
made a mistake a long time ago a bad
business decision that I I decided to
participate in selling a questionable
product now
because of that I know the system I know
that Steve Bannon will serve those days
I also know that there's a two-tiered
and really honestly if you if you want
to go deeper it's a three-tier justice
system in this country not just in state
governments but the federal as well that
is why Steve Bannon and Donald Trump
have been able to skate the law with
their crimes for so long
this system that we have in this country
is a three-tiered justice system
people like you and I we get caught up
in the justice system we don't get to
delay we don't get to to have people oh
well special Master this and special
master that even look at the case of
Michael Cohen the federal case made
against Michael Cohen Michael Cohen and
a special Master but Michael Cohen
Michael Cohen did not sit out
and just walk around doing whatever the
hell he wanted that is not exactly how
it worked
so there is a three-tier justice system
in this country
and I say three tiered because the top
two tiers
are carved out for white folk and Rich
Folk
sometimes it's a little bit overlap of
both
and that bottom deer really
is the tear that puts the the foot on
the back of Americans who are
marginalized
and that's the stuff we need to stop now
we will we will get Justice in the case
of Steve Bannon and Donald Trump I am
very confident
I am very confident folks that we are
going to see Justice with Steve Bannon
and Donald Trump and the Trump
organization and their [ __ ] allies
Peter Navarro Mark Meadows cash Patel
Christina Bob all these people who have
instructed Justice all the way down to
Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy Giuliani
and the like Jeannie Thomas all these
State electors these people who were
participating in the state elector
scheme John Eastman Jeffrey Clark
possibly Lindsey Graham I'm telling you
they're going to see Justice
it's going to take a while Justice takes
a long time especially in a federal
court again I know this from my
experience
and no one should have to experience the
justice system in this country but if
you do things that are questionable
especially if you overtly tried to
overthrow the government of the United
States you are probably going to feel
the justice system
Hammer you that is more than likely what
you're gonna find when you try to
overthrow an election of the United
States
so today it's Monday October 24th and
yes we are so close to an election and
we have to keep our eye on the prize
folks we really do
the prize is the poll that is going to
be counted
after November 8th that is the most
important poll right now that is the
most important thing that is the thing
that you should be talking about the
most even as these subjects come up and
the reason why I say this because that
is exactly what I'm going to Pivot to
if you believe that the three-tier
justice system in this country is unfair
and unjust and I know it's not going to
change with one vote it won't it won't
change with one vote it won't change
with one term
but if you trust
that the Maga Republican party who is
capitulating to criminals like Donald
Trump Rudy Giuliani cash Patel Rudy
there we go Rudy Giuliani again
Senator Lindsey Graham
and the like
if you are okay if you think that's who
you want to run the justice department
you just look at what Donald Trump said
this weekend at his rally
just look at it what he's going to do
he's going to jail dissidents
he said jail any [ __ ] journalist jail
them all until they get to the bottom of
the leaker so here's a guy
who's claiming he wants to jail people
who leak government information
you can't make this [ __ ] up
he literally that is exactly what he did
he stole top secret information kept it
unsafe
foreign giving the ability
for Bad actors to get their hands on it
and he wants to jail journalists for
leaking a Supreme Court decision which
more than likely the leak came from the
right in the first place probably was
Genie Thomas if you want to know the
honest truth I mean that's who I think
it is I have no evidence of that but
I mean why wouldn't you believe the
crazy Q Anon lady would be leaking all
kinds of information that her husband's
telling her why wouldn't you believe
that
it's not that far of a [ __ ] stretch
is it
so if you're if you're deciding right
now
with your vote
of how you're going to vote
because let's side that and both sides
same and this side that and this side
that this listen
do you want the people
who want to strip away Medicare and
Social Security from Americans strip it
away they want to take away
your Social Security and your Medicare
for good
do you want them having control of the
economy
is that what you want do you want people
who absolutely deny
facts right in front of their face
that this election was free fair and the
people spoke 81 million people told
Donald Trump to go [ __ ] himself
we see it in the 60 Minutes interview
from over the weekend with Dominion that
Dominion told Fox News and provided the
evidence over and over and over again to
them that what you're saying is [ __ ]
lies
you want the people who who [ __ ] lie
and believe like Kerry Lake that this
election the freest and fairest election
the most scrutinized election we have
ever had because that fat slob is a
crybaby
do you want them in charge of your
government
and I'm not just talking about your
national government
all the way down to the dog catcher
that's who you want in charge you want a
Republican party who supports Dr Oz who
murdered little puppies for his little
experiments for his [ __ ] snake oil
[ __ ] you want them to be in charge of
the dog catcher get the [ __ ] out of here
with that nonsense
and it's all a scam anyways that there's
big support for these fools
don't believe what the media is telling
you these polls are [ __ ] wrong and
they're nonsense they're [ __ ] the
only reason you should listen to the
poll is if it terrifies you enough to go
to the poll if it motivates you to vote
that's when you should listen because
the only poll that matters is the one
that is counted on November 8th
that's it that's it and you get to
decide that poll you with your vote and
your voice
yes you can use your voice to talk to
people to make sure they vote make sure
they get out an early vote make sure
they get their ballot cast and counted
it is super important that this turnout
is massive
not just to win not just to win but to
send another message
we have not had the ability to send a
national message with our ballots since
January 6. think about this the 2020
election was before January 6th that's
the last national election we had and
eight million more people told Donald
Trump to go [ __ ] himself than wanted him
81 million people told Donald Trump we
do not want you to be president you suck
and it sucks to suck
we have not had a national election and
since January 6. when the Republicans
revealed themselves as domestic
terrorists as traitors
as sycophants to Trump
and they're all in baby I don't know if
you've seen the video over the weekend
from The Mike Flynn [ __ ] Q Anon
religious cult rally it's some crazy ass
[ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a cult folks
it's a [ __ ] cult
and they're saying crazy [ __ ] and
they're telling me what the hell they're
gonna do they're not hiding it they want
a fascist State because they want to get
rid of you
I'm talking to you if you think the way
that most people in this country believe
that we are a democracy there is freedom
rights and Liberty they want to get rid
of you
you are a threat
to their existence the way they see it
because you will be intolerant of their
intolerance
and they just cannot tolerate that
but we must stay fast we must lean in
we are we are just two weeks away
from sending the largest message since
2020.
and we must send that message nationally
we must pile these fascists under
mountains and mountains of votes it is
crucially important that we do this
and I implore you if you can early vote
in Texas do it today
do it today find two people
three people to do it today make sure
they find two people three people to do
it today I don't know if you've seen the
videos of the lines in Atlanta for the
early voting for Georgia but it is
giving me the feels
I don't care who those people are voting
for I do not mind if you go cast your
ballot for a fascist that is your right
what gives me the feels is democracy is
at work
and I know I'm very confident
as we watch democracy at work that the
pro-democracy people and candidates and
policies will win
that is what democracy delivers now it's
a long hard slog folks this isn't going
to happen overnight
it isn't going to be Democrats win and
then oh hooray we saved the country no
these people are not gonna go away
they're not going to give in they're not
going to relent we must not either as
soon
as these ballots are counted after
November 8th
and we and we have fended off
the threat to our democracy in this
election the next election will be the
most important one but let's keep our
eye on the prize
it is most important now more than ever
that we come together as a country as a
people
and save our country
because it is in Peril if they win
and and if not if you don't think so I'm
gonna show you the proof today here on
the Tony Michaels podcast so thanks for
joining me just like you join me every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch don't forget
to hit that subscribe button if you're
here on YouTube you're not going to want
to miss a thing
also go over to Twitter and follow us at
Tony Michael's pod you can follow me at
the Tony Michaels and Gabe Sanchez
Chicago at I am Gabe Sanchez my co-host
you can also download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google
and if you're on Facebook right now I
know you're out there on the mightiest
touch Facebook page go over to our page
at the Tony Michaels I've been posting
some videos and memes over there
everyone really likes the memes
so if you want to share meet political
memes around and normally they have
profanity in them I'm not gonna lie and
Facebook is
Facebook is probably gonna ban me I
don't know and I just go over there and
and if you want to spread around some
memes with some profanity and come on
over come on over and follow me Anthony
Tony Michaels on Facebook also get in on
the twitch conversation and some people
like the twitch chat so go go download
the Twitch app on your cell phone if you
know and it's free I don't get anything
to download it just go over to uh the
the Twitch app you can just type in the
Tony Michaels or the Tony Michaels
podcast you'll find us over on Twitch
and you can watch there and chat with
the good folks there also
if you want to stay warm while you're in
line voting
go to store.dtonymichaels.com you can
pick up your Liberty sweater hoodie or
zip up jacket the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty it
is our motto here the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty grab yours today make sure
you're warm when you're standing in line
voting go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that's
store.the tonymichaels.com and don't
forget to grab a t-shirt either we got
some we got some coffee mugs over there
you should really check it out you know
I I tell you I got the I got the fascism
sucks design I think I'm gonna put the
fascism sucks design up over on this
store.d Tony michaels.com today so go
that later this afternoon and check it
out see if you can find it and then
spread it around social media if you
will also we run on your support you are
the greatest audience in the world the
greatest audience in the world and I'm
so glad to have you here every single
weekday
all two hours every day and I wish we
could go to three maybe we will soon go
to three
but I love having you here we run on
your support the shares the the
confidence I I got a ton of DMS
um this weekend
um telling me telling me how how how
great they love listening to the show
and more than anything I want to express
how much I love having you here
to listen it is most important I want to
get I want to give some love to the
moderators in the chat they do a
fantastic job here on YouTube to keep
keep the trolls at Bay
and keep the nonsense at Bay but give
them some love because I know you guys
come here not just to hear me but you
come to chat with your friends in the
YouTube chat and a live chat on Twitch
but we run on your support So share this
show with your family your friends go
download it if you want to give a tip
just go to Tony Michaels dot live Tony
Michaels dot live and you can give a tip
there one time tip or you can set it up
monthly now we appreciate all of you
every single audience member out there
you are how we run you are how we
operate here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
so don't forget to give us support any
way you can even if it's just a tweet a
retweet a share give the link to your
family your friends even that that Trump
supporting Uncle Earl of yours everyone
we're going to get to the shitless
Roundup because I got to show you this
video I gotta show you this video this
this hero this Patriot
um challenging these armed Intimidators
out in Mesa Arizona who were who were
intimidating people at a ballot drop box
folks don't go anywhere we're going to
show you that video right after these
messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
I gotta tell you I've watched a movie
[Music]
it's a great movie I want to show you
the trailer here if I let's see if we
can load this up I want to show you the
trailer for this this movie it's called
the game is up
the game is up a friend of mine and
Melissa Jo partier
Peltier I think that and I get her name
wrong it's French name yeah you gotta
forgive me I'm like hillbilly I'm like
Oh Billy what am I supposed to do I I
don't get names right all the time
it's not my fault
Meez Mesa Hillbillies but that this film
is called the game is up I did an
interview with her
um she had her Twitter account hacked so
we couldn't we couldn't play the
interview because I I wanted to make
sure she could promote it on her Twitter
page but I want to show the trailer to
you here if I can it's a great film you
should go watch it but more than
anything I really think this is um super
important you can actually share this
movie
with your family and your friends
and the reason why is this movie is
about people who were Trump supporters
who decided that he wasn't the best
after all
it really does show and I one person
you're gonna know from this film is Joe
Walsh Joe Walsh tried to run for
president in 2020 on the Republican
ticket because he was trying to
challenge Donald Trump but this film
is it is a great film a lot of it was
filmed during covid
so they had to really work through the
covid
um pandemic
and try to make this film but Melissa
Joe did such a great job in in directing
this film and getting this film so I
wanna I wanna bring more light to it so
let me play the trailer for you right
now when you're in the conservative
media world like I was in you are told
to say every day that Donald Trump walks
on water
thank you
I was told by my bosses to only say good
things about Donald Trump I told them to
go
most of our opinions about Donald Trump
do not come from CNN or from MSNBC
orphan Fox most of our opinions about
Donald Trump come from Donald Trump
himself
how can you I mean any line about
liberals lying about Democrats lying
about Trump it's kind of hard to invest
I know quite a few uh people my age who
are in the Republican Party who they're
thinking about leaving the Republican
Party they're thinking about leaving
this trumpism this phenomenon I threw up
the red flag I threw up the White Flag
as a warning that this was bad
agricultural policy and it was going to
hurt us for a long time
foreign
so there it is there it is the game is
up you just go to the game is
upmovie.com the game is up movie.com let
me let me put it in the chat here so you
guys can go find this website
um because you can find it in different
places Amazon is the best way to go
watch this thing uh but the the game is
up movie.com uh go watch this movie
we'll be talking about it more this week
um so you might go watch it that way
when we have Melissa on I I already can
the interview I just gotta I want to cut
it up and I didn't want to just do one
interview for this movie because I truly
I truly like this movie I believe it
gives a good way for even drunk
supporters to watch this to watch this
movie and and really evaluate what their
delusion is because these Trump
supporters who are disillusioned
um as As Trump supporters tell their
stories
and it's it's highly interesting on how
they became disillusioned so go check it
out again
it is the game is
upmovie.com the game is upmovie.com
we'll talk about it more this week let's
do this we got a lot of speaking of
movies and clips we got a lot of Clips
to get to I think Gabe Sanchez is going
to be joining us in just a few seconds
so let's do this let's go to the
shitless Roundup let's round up some
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends start
the countdown
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the shitlist Roundup but we
round up all the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends boy do we have a lot going
on this morning uh as you know Ted Cruz
is a piece of [ __ ] he's a piece of
garbage no one likes Ted Cruz at all
like nobody
I mean is can you find one person that
likes Ted Cruz I don't know
[ __ ] you Ted Cruz was the tile today I
actually like this style Gabe Sanchez
and he does such a great job with our
art here and boy talk about world-class
art right here this is this is one of
the best YouTube tiles you're going to
see today
because of how it's constructed and who
it's constructed
four against I don't know why did he
think he could go to this [ __ ]
baseball game and not get booed
how is this even a possibility that he
really thought he could show up and a
New York Yankees game in Astros colors
and not get booed
how is this even a possibility
did he really believe that he wasn't
going to get called out
no way no way let's let's watch one of
the videos that we have here from the
Yankees game where Ted Cruz is walking
out mid game he can't even make it
through the stretch here let's let's
listen
foreign
but boy he really lays in the Ted Cruz
he really lays in the takers this is one
of the best of the videos that I found
uh today of of hecklers telling Ted Cruz
where the [ __ ] to go and he really they
do a great job there's also um pictures
of people take Crews turned around
you're gonna wave to a few folks and
everyone's flipping him off listen
I'm not saying that it is only because
Ted Cruz is in New York City
but
Ted Cruz going to the Yankee Stadium and
Astros colors when he's just pretending
to be an Astros fan because that's
really what he's doing here
I mean the guy bought like second row
seats behind the home plate they're
probably over three thousand dollar
seats right they're probably over three
thousand dollar seats he claims so often
that it's the elite that are the
problems that are the [ __ ]
the the liberal Elites you know the ones
getting their student loans paid back
the Slackers they're the problems of our
country but this [ __ ] can afford
thousands of dollars to go sit for a few
innings for a God damn photo up
at Yankee Stadium
literally that's exactly what he did he
paid thousands of dollars to go to a
Yankees game in Houston Astro colors sit
in the second row for a photo op
and and he's bitching about liberals
being Elites and calling people who get
ten thousand dollars relief from their
student loan debt Slackers you pile of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you pile of [ __ ] [ __ ]
how Americans
have can stomach going into a polling
booth and vote for anyone who supports
this kind of garbage where he pays a
third
he probably paid at least 25 to 35
percent
for the ticket that he went for a photo
op for
the amount of money
that people are going to get their
student debt relieved for a photo op
do you have any idea Ted Cruz what that
ten thousand dollars will do for average
everyday Working Families
do you have any idea no he doesn't he
has no [ __ ] clue
because this piece of [ __ ] is willing to
spend thousands of dollars on a photo op
to go to Yankee Stadium where he knows
he's gonna get booed he knows people
aren't going to like him I mean where
does he go where people like him in the
first place really Jesus Christ maybe
that's why he came back from Cancun he
went down there like Boo get the [ __ ]
out of here and he left just like he did
here at the game before the stretch
so
if you want to put this booing and Ted
Cruz into context because I know people
are having fun with it this morning I'm
having a great I'm having a great time
listening to these people boo the [ __ ]
out of Ted Cruz
it warms my heart
I mean it makes me feel like a million
bucks this morning this was better than
a cup of coffee and I know my co-host
doesn't drink coffee but Gabe how much
how much energy did these videos of Ted
Cruz getting booed this morning give you
oh I mean
the amount of excitement we played we
played Rudy Giuliani you remember the
one where he was getting into a truck
they've never probably been in a pickup
truck before him and him and Andrew
Giuliani they were on the campaign Trail
right yeah you [ __ ] traitor you
[ __ ] traitor and and you know and
that video was just oh it was just so
nice and so sweet but this these booing
of Ted Cruz is just fantastic I mean
anytime anytime I can see a video of
somebody saying go [ __ ] yourself or you
[ __ ] you or
you're a [ __ ] or whatever it might be to
one of these fascists
um it's a it's a great day a great way
to I mean like look I went to bed with a
smile on my face I woke up with a smile
on my face because I was like I wonder
if this will still be a topic tomorrow I
mean it probably will and then when I
woke up everyone was still ragging on
him I was like great and some of the
best Ted Cruz Clips are going around the
internet today right because there's no
there's no shortage of Ted Cruz looking
like a total Jackass the best thing
about it like there there will be no
shortage obviously because they were a
lot of [ __ ] people at that game and
there were a lot of people at that game
who are like yeah we feel the same way
middle finger middle finger go [ __ ]
yourself go [ __ ] yourself go back to
Cancun you know eat it [ __ ] eat [ __ ] Ted
Cruz I think I we we kind of this this
moment when I first watched this video
it sparked an idea that we should make a
t-shirt eat [ __ ] Ted Cruz right and I
think I think we should really try to
get this one out I made a a few attempts
and Gabe is like no you're doing it all
wrong
um I'm working on it right now sometimes
sometimes I do a t-shirt to design a
gauge like yeah thumbs up and sometimes
he's like nope that's not no the way the
way I saw last night I was like yeah
it's not like the the idea is good it
was just the execution
oh well right right I I had a good
concept as well yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean people won't work people will like
the concept yeah yeah because it's nice
warm and fluffy like it's like yeah it
makes you feel good
especially when the the image makes you
feel good and the words eat [ __ ] Ted
Cruz that makes you right makes you feel
I mean it just makes you feel all warm
inside yeah to me no no it does I'm just
I'm just wondering like are there more
like are there unicorns you know I well
you know I'm I thought about that right
I thought about that as well that design
everyone I know you're like what the
hell are they talking about right now
but maybe we'll get this design release
today or tomorrow and we will uh we'll
show you but what I want to do first is
show you the rest of this this video
I've got what I think is a breaking news
but we could do it after okay okay let's
finish this it's only got a few more
seconds here let's listen to the uh the
booing of Ted Cruz
[Music]
thank you
I'm surprised nobody like accidentally
Spiel like spilled like beer on him they
like there was one like you know it is
it is hard not to accidentally spill
beer on tankers
I think there's a couple things in mind
right like if I was at a game and I just
spent 16 bucks on a beer which really
that's what it is you're spending like
12 12 16 bucks whatever it is
um
and you're like ah I paid all this money
for this beer so I don't want to waste
it but then you're also like would it
really be wasting it if I just like went
in for a selfie all accidentally spilled
it kind of thing because I did see some
people who were like taking selfies but
then they were like getting people
around to give him the middle finger
which was hilarious like everyone was
setting him up for failure here and he
was like oh hey yeah okay you know like
I I'm going because I have to go right
not because I'm literally being booed
out of the stadium right now what the
the craziest part is this guy's been
running around for the last month
talking about how people receiving ten
thousand dollars of relief on student
debt are Slackers and this guy I I don't
know how much the ticket was where he's
sitting but I think someone said online
that um a seat like that at Yankee
Stadium where he was sitting in a
regular season game is like two thousand
dollars 2500 hours so I'm sure that
ticket I'm sure that ticket was at least
three maybe more that three thousand
dollars or more which is which is which
is almost most almost just a third or a
quarter maybe maybe if it was four or
five I'll just have a what he's saying
is is people receiving Deb or Slackers
this [ __ ] paying money that
much money just to go for a photo op to
show up at a baseball game to show that
he was there wait wait wait are you are
you saying that that Ted Cruz is like
part of an Elite Class well I mean it
that can afford these like luxury items
would be disparaging to him since he
hates the elite
um even though he is one that [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] this is this is still all
the projection right it's the projection
of the elites and all that and that's
really our breaking news because we have
breaking news here should we play the
should we play this yeah let's play that
here
all right there's the breaking news
title so what we have here is Justice
Clarence Thomas temporary blocks
Graham's testimony in the Georgia
election interference probe there's a
lot of stuff packed into this headline
Gabe um first off Justice Clarence
Thomas this is the reason why Lindsey
Graham took this to the court is because
Clarence Thomas has the ability to make
this decision on his own
um now we watched as Amy Coney Barrett
last week
um decided that she would turn down the
effort of Republicans speaking of
student loans to
um stop the student loan payment relief
plan that Biden has said into place so
it's the same sort of thing the other
thing too is the 9-0 decision on uh
Trump's document case that they could
have decided on that the Justice could
decide on their own but they didn't they
took it to the court in this case it
looks like Clarence Thomas is using his
authority and this is why we should
really investigate the [ __ ] out of this
trees and this piece of [ __ ] and this
insurrectionist he he is married to a Q
and I'm crazy
um they were definitely communicating
about the election
and here he is making decision on a
testimony that would affect elections
the election that he was interfering in
um by by communicating with his wife so
this with his wife communicating with
the chief of staff and uh overtly
inadvertently I guess you should say no
no big deal just right just cooing just
cueing just you know it's just a regular
old coup game yeah it's just a regular
seditious sext no so so it looks like uh
Justice Clarence Thomas is going to be
the cause for a lot of yelling and
screaming today because um this is
probably a really it's going to be seen
as a bias uh decision
um in that this has to do with the 2020
election and his wife Jeannie Thomas was
actively trying to subvert the election
if not
um embroiled in this conspiracy for
these State electors I don't know if um
the Department of Justice and the grand
and Jerry and DC has subpoenaed her yet
or not for that scheme and conspiracy in
the state electors but again Gabe
because of my experience with this stuff
normally
a grand jury if they don't subpoena you
for your testimony you are a Target if
they do subpoena you for Testimony you
are generally not a Target yet yeah you
are not a Target yet in Federal grand
jury so in this case of Clarence Thomas
Jeannie Thomas and Lindsey Graham We
will see more drama play out in our
political sphere now it says temporary
blocks yeah I'm not sure if he if he's
going to take this to the court and have
you been able to read um this article
because I guess I guess Clarence Thomas
could currently just block it for now
and then set it for it to go before The
Supreme Court so in the article it says
like the reason uh you know obviously
that Graham went to him was because that
decisions like this go to Thomas who
handles these emergency requests so it
frees the litigation while the Justice
weigh Graham's plea on the Supreme Court
you know as they as they deal with it so
it sounds like it's a pause for them to
do a deeper kind of assessment as to
what's going on so he has the immediate
ability to say nope
stop it right now
let let us take a moment and then we'll
like Circle back with you and then give
you decision right well and and that and
that goes to play uh because we are
again we're just just over two weeks
away from the next uh election the
midterm today is Texas they're starting
to vote
um and maybe that's what Clarence Thomas
is trying to do here is to just delay
and remember like what what they're
asking about they're just two phone
calls they are oh it's only about and
it's phone calls that Lindsey Graham
made not that right not phone calls he
took yeah he made these phone calls he
made that's a very phone call right
that's a very distinct thing that people
need to know is Lindsey Graham actually
phoned to Georgia which is very which is
kind of funny that we talk about the
election and early voting and
um this case being
um temporary blocked by Thomas is
because people are lining up in Atlanta
like crazy to bring the turnout is huge
so we're having that go on as as this
and um which leads me to my next subject
in the shitless Roundup we we watched
last week um and I don't know you were
gone a couple days because you were
shooting your uh deep State propaganda
video for the George Soros Medical Group
yep
um but um it was a real thing right real
it's absolutely 100 I mean it was a pain
gig that was the first time George Soros
actually paid me really so did he show
up and like pay you with a bag of cash
or was it he had he had a man that was a
proxy and then he was holding up an iPad
that had a message from George oh so
George was busy recorded yeah George was
it looked like George was flying he was
in it I mean he's pretty busy man he's
writing a lot of antifa checks man and
he's organizing these antifa uh cookie
sales and bake sales he's doing a lot of
work out there yeah for antifa in the
deep but I can say that George Soros
pays very well
very well we watched last week
um these videos of these domestic
terrorists intimidating voters who
dropped their ballots in a secure box in
Maricopa County
um there were some that were standing
outside that just looked like a bunch of
Rubes
um they were standing out in daylight
with cameras and they were questioned by
a news station news organization last
week
about why they were doing it one of them
really gave away that it was uh This
Clean Q Anon votes or clean Qing on
elections USA I'm not sure what the
organization's called you know I get
names confused Gabe I get names confused
I get them turned around I just can't
sometimes place my brain on a name
um so I I don't remember exactly what
the organization's called but they he
kind of gave it away in the interview
the woman didn't she was like nope no
comment no comment no comment but then
we got news that there were armed masked
people in in body armor watching these
Drive courses you're gonna have people
cosplaying well I mean they are I mean
they deem themselves all domestic
terrorists right
um so that's that's how that is working
uh you just sent me another a link here
what is that uh this is an American News
another breaking news okay so what's
local to you actually I mean it's not
it's
it's
not a great topic right but it's an
everyday occurrence let's do this let's
go to this breaking news since you got
it here and then we will come back to
the video clip
um it's actually the video clip is from
Mesa Arizona
um so this breaking news here let's give
the uh let's give the music here if I
can find it here I get it
all right this is not good um breaking
news this is more horrible breaking news
um two killed in high school shooting in
Missouri that is the state that I'm in
uh the suspect is dead I don't know if
that's included in the two
um looks like uh two victims in the susp
and the suspect so three two victims and
the suspect died after he opened fire
inside of St Louis high school Monday
morning uh St Louis police chief Mike
sacks said so it looks like this is in a
um St Louis High School Sac said the
teen and the adult died in a shooting
inside Central Visual and Performing
Arts High School eight people were
hospitalized the ferris injuries it's
unclear how many were from gunshot
wounds
um sack said that the suspect has not
been identified
but appeared to be roughly 20 years old
so this seems like a situation where it
is not a current student and maybe it is
a former student of this high school but
it is a young person again with a gun
going into a school and murdering people
um sad state in our country this is the
reason why we must we must we must have
our birth voices heard in less than two
weeks right and if you had the
opportunity right now in Missouri
there's not a lot of early voting right
there's just not unless you are have an
absentee reason or something of that
nature but in Texas right now you can
early vote in Georgia you can earn the
vote and don't think that it doesn't
matter in your state
if if about these issues because there
are National issues there are National
things that that people who want to have
um actual sensible gun legislation past
can do at a federal level so please I
urge you if this headline upsets you let
it motivate you to go vote for the party
and the people who are pro-democracy and
want to listen to the people 70 over 70
percent of the country want sensible gun
reform at least red flag laws at a bare
minimum in background check so please
please uh um I I hate to hear this
especially in my home state that sounds
like a teacher and a student have been
killed in the St Louis high school so
let's go back go ahead oh I was gonna
something that you brought up so like
specifically around gun violence you
know there was a story that my
girlfriend was telling me yesterday
about how in the UK during the 60s I
think up until 71 I think it was
um there was an increase in suicides in
the UK a and they were finding that a
lot of people were committing suicide by
placing their head in an oven right and
they saw that basically they identified
that people were doing this and it was
easy to do because it was a cold gas uh
oven oh so they would be in carbon
monoxide carbon monoxide was a byproduct
of it and because it was also easier to
do there wasn't the ability for people
to like stop themselves and say like oh
I've got to do these other steps in
order to you know take my own life so
the UK said well there's clearly a
problem
we also just can't say that people are
committing suicide for this so we need
to uh totally redo the ovens that we
have in the UK so there's a problem they
identified what you mean they changed
the entire how they make the products
exactly exactly or and also you know by
which the gas that they provide but the
important I mean you know obviously the
main thing is they couldn't outwardly
say of course that it was the ovens and
the gas were the problem but they
changed it and said oh we need to do
maintenance we do this we need to update
it anyway what you saw after that 1971
was a decrease
in suicides and of course we look at
this country and we say oh well we have
an increase in gun violence
like what's the solution right the
solution would be hey maybe we should
regulate guns we make stricter rules we
should have actual you need a permit you
need you need this and you can't have
these loopholes to buy guns and these
these uh these conventions or what have
you in a black market
but instead obviously we'll have
Republicans the Republicans who are up
for either re-election or they're up for
an office as a first time
and those are the people that want to
put more guns out those are the people
who want to restrict rights for women
those are the people who want to take
away the accessibility to to certain
things that you have as Citizens so
that is what we need to do when when it
comes to November 8th we need to vote in
the people in the Democrats who actually
deliver
and help stop these fascist policies
which would be more guns on the street
as if that's a solution and this is you
know a sad story today in in your state
of Missouri we're seeing this as another
school shooting and yet Republicans will
look at it and say
oh we don't we don't see a problem here
right and and also speaking of UK UK
also had a gun problem they did that
Australia had a gun problem they
addressed that and we're you know you
see a cause and effect of those changes
but here in America because uh
Republicans have power and they hold the
majority in certain ways they're able to
manipulate the laws how they want and
actually not take care and represent
their their constituents so this
November make sure to vote for the
people who actually stand up and
represent you and deliver what you need
whether it's student debt relief health
care
uh safety you know those are the things
that are at stake in this election
and don't let them intimidate you either
into your in into not voting or not
dropping a mail-in ballot in a secure
box [ __ ] that [ __ ] I have um I have a
video here of a person who um and I've
been speaking to her this morning I'm
actually going to see if we can get her
on the show
um tomorrow yeah so um uh this this uh
hero this Patriot you see this guy
sitting in the chair right there that's
the the armed gang with the mask on
now this is in Mesa Arizona
um she told me this morning that she was
uh dressed up as a nun
uh the lady who took this video oh nice
yeah so because I think the most I saw
was her Shoe Right video yeah because
this is a video from her camera from her
perspective
um but this is one of the short ones
here where she just kind of she just
kind of introduces herself to these
these domestic terrorists here watch
foreign
nice to meet you
hi
oh why why are they so refrigerated you
know what's funny is people who are
recording people that do uh to expose
their identity don't want their identity
exposed it's almost like it's almost
like when a bunch of online Anonymous
people you know come in and say stuff
about people having Anonymous names
online it's really it's really funny how
that works it's really funny other words
it's very very interesting that they're
kind of Rich that those people are so
quick to throw Jabs anonymously from a
keyboard right but then as soon as you
as soon as you expose them or identify
oh do this yo you can't do this
right don't don't show my face bro same
same here same here same here you get
these people trying trying to basically
round up information on people legally
dropping ballots in a secure box so that
they can intimidate them and use other
folks to and it groups and to intimidate
it's almost like they know what they're
doing is wrong Ah that's weird that's
weird that they would come with their
faces hidden what is this thing on his
on his shirt it's like it's a body Cam
that he probably purchased from Amazon
because I don't know if it's in this
video or if it's another video
he puts it in her face trying to block
her from recording he's like you got a
camera I've got a camera and it's like
dude you bought that at like [ __ ] 99
cent store right well and I couldn't
figure out what it was in that one where
he's like putting it in her face I
didn't know it was like a light RV thing
is no she has she has a light uh either
on her phone or she's in a bright ass
light that's pointing at them and he's
using the camera to block the light so
she can't record at night oh so so here
she she sent me a message here she said
um I was interviewed by a local station
while wearing her nun costume so
so hopefully
an interview with her tomorrow and I
just want to ask her a few questions
what gave her this idea and um yeah I
want to thank her for for for this
content
um and we'll probably just do like a
phone interview so that way and you know
she didn't have to give us her Identity
or anything like that it just but I want
to confirm that it's her I want to
confirm a few facts about it and make
sure that we can actually uh nail that
down I just want to point out these are
the same [ __ ] cooks that are part of
the proud boys part of The Oath Keepers
these are all these [ __ ] cosplaying
dudes that get some military boots from
the military supply store they put on a
little flak jacket and then they've got
some bear spray and a body cam but the
man
Coca-Cola man right well that's that's
what I don't understand he why not Diet
Coke well but he should know not to
drink Coca-Cola they're a woke company
yeah I don't know if he knows that is
true they're a woke company this guy is
woke
right yes whoa but you know again you
would you look at a guy right here that
clearly knows this intimidation is
illegal right it's a [ __ ] joke well
watch watch why because I'm going to
show you the rest of this video and then
I want to show you the video where they
scatter like cockroaches that's why yeah
how are you
why would you need to block your license
plate oh that's weird yeah that seems
weird okay
she was just trying to be patriotic yeah
you're just trying to make sure she
waved the black why would you why would
you why would you paste it to your
license plate why wouldn't you be flying
it patriotically loudly and proudly I
mean it seems only like common sense to
me now the video that I really find
interesting here oh let's see if I can
this is weird did you know that you can
post more than one video on a on a
Twitter thread now look at this yeah
yeah this is look at this so she's got
she's got two videos posted here you see
this so she got two here look at that
now that's where that's where the people
have the they've set up the the floor
tile meme right somebody holding
something up and then they put in the
the top left corner right so so now if
anyone doesn't know this and maybe is it
available to everybody I don't think
it's available to everyone oh okay you
can't I don't think you could do it on
desktop yet you could do it from the app
mobile iPad iPhone but this is new and
now I'm I'm making Twitter news here I
guess but let's see let's see if I can
get this program because I haven't tried
this yet this is me there it goes okay
so you just click on it goes full screen
whoa yeah when I first saw the slip I
was like what's going on here whoa
that's that's almost a crotch so this is
the uh the domestic terrorist uh uh
Intimidators crotch I don't know who
this is that that Buckle is buckling
right real tight there yeah well now
this is when the cops come over they get
involved watch this right
there he is waving that thing around in
her face that's little dick energy if
I've ever seen it yeah
he's real tough with the
um
don't feel me I'll film you dude this is
very much
as he holds a cigarette God this guy's
such a [ __ ] Karen
okay let me let me turn up the volume
here see if I can get the volume up a
bit so we can hear the uh the other the
fascist in uniforms
um oh God damn it okay I just want to
say it again anyone who intimidates you
at the polls obviously is illegal but
also if they do that [ __ ] they got the
smallest dick ever right well you can
see that there's not much of a there's
no we got a full frontal shot there that
guy is I mean cigarettes his cigarettes
is a bigger package he's he's this guy
is clearly a dick but he's also
little little dick energy let's see what
the let's see what the officers have to
say
I'm just sitting here I'm not even
communicating
yeah I'm not saying anything
[Music]
I'm just sitting here I'm not even
communicating with them I love this lady
so she she sees these people
intimidating people and she's like you
know what why can't I just do the same
thing to them yeah right if it's totally
legal in the in the in the sheriff's
deputies are willing to let these people
sit there and intimidate people then
they they have to let me do it to them
to record them and just sit I'm just
sitting here I'm just sitting here
enjoying the Stars okay I just decided
this was the spot now it's funny because
they actually lay claim to the parking
spaces and the cops buy that at first
until this lady says them listen I'm
sitting right here
you're videoing us what
oh
did we do that
I'm just sitting here I'm not even
communicating with them
you're in our space he says as if he
owns the parking spaces I'm not sure
what this means but watch what it's a
public part right right well that's the
argument that they would make
if someone was challenging them and this
this lady's brilliant how she does this
but watch how the officer again and
responds to this guy laying claim to
these parking spaces my girlfriend's car
I understand
oh yeah yeah okay yeah yeah you're white
you're white you can have these faces
sure sure you're white you look like you
look like you would support us and so
you definitely you definitely laid claim
to these and that's you know Sovereign
citizenship type stuff so yeah sure
these parking spaces are now yours it's
your real estate you own them do you
need a deed sir so that you can prove it
oh my God this is designated really any
individual I'm sitting right here
I'm not even communicating with it and
she totally just just destroys this idea
that they're hurt their parking spaces
she's like there's no car here and I'm
just sitting here I'm not even blocking
a parking space just because they're
intimidated by me doesn't mean it's
intimidation right right is that net in
that the case here she's brilliant
um it looks like you guys are
antagonizing no he's putting that in my
face I'm sitting down he's with a gun
standing over top of me I'm sitting down
he's got a gun too he's yeah well maybe
what about him he's got a gun too yeah
well this guy doesn't have a [ __ ] gun
at its hip in my face also this guy is
some sort of either with the sheriff or
Police Department or well it's a sheriff
it says sheriff on his vest so right you
know I mean I I guess he has a sheriff's
costume on which most of them are
cosplaying into most degree even though
they have a a license too I mean if
you're Mike Lindell you get a little pin
just like Carson Walker that's like a
thing now on the Republican well unless
it's a federal police officer and then
there and then they're bad right right
back to Blue and less exactly they hold
you accountable trained with the FBI did
he wins no I already invented the FBI
Herschel Walker he invented it no
there's a different acronym that he
invented it's uh he invented CTE oh okay
yeah not FBI he invented CTE well it's
all confusing especially when you talk
to Herschel about it okay let's let's
listen are you intimidated by him can we
just get away from each other we're away
well we were here we've been here for
ever I'm not even communicating with
them
I'm not even communicating
I didn't I didn't stick I didn't oh my
God Gabe did you hear she was taking
pictures of their license plate how dare
she wait wait how dare she that's
illegal that is illegal that's a crime
arrest her back up back up you're you're
telling me it's illegal to take photos
of someone else's license plate when
this is the group that's taking photos
of other people's license plate at the
polling place it's very it's it's it um
I don't know if it's supposed to make
sense really honestly well I mean right
for me not for thee right right yeah but
that's what that's I mean man it's
fascism that's what they want I mean
that's that's the reason why this lady
is such a hero is because she's
challenging them with their own stupid
[ __ ] logic their own stupid logic
like look just because you think you're
intimidating people
like she's showing how it she's in
they're intimidating people right like
she's because she's this lady is not
intimidating people from a drop box this
lady is only simply being in their space
and taking pictures and they feel
intimidated right so I mean what they
claim what they claim they're doing
which is not what they're doing their
intention is to intimidate
you see you see the woman here you know
again backs up has the phone recording
and then covers her face up like right
like why would you need why would you
feel that if you're just sitting there
talking right I mean why do you because
I mean like inherently people who want
to cover up their phase and they don't
want to be shown or revealed feels
afraid or shameful that they don't want
their identity to be you know exposed
why would you why would you have that
feeling why why do you feel
like oh shoot I I can't I can't be seen
like I can't let other people know that
I was here why do you feel shame because
you know it's wrong because you know
what you're doing intimidation is
illegal and you know that you are trying
to support a fascist State I think
there's more to this story I think
there's more to this story but let's
watch this video and then we'll watch
the next one because I think the next
one is is really good too let's watch it
listen
please
well you can sit down somewhere else
yourself
I love the goal of these people I think
they can tell people what to do but when
they're told what to do now you like
that man I can make it right rare I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna comply or
whatever the hell right here's the next
video
now let me let me get it this is weird
this whole two videos in a tweet thing
it's messing with my system here I'm not
liking it but um we'll we'll work
through it you see they're now they're
packing it up and this is the video
where they scatter like cockroach just
because they figure out that law
enforcement just like law enforcement
can't help that they're sitting there
can't help that this ladies they don't
get what rights are they don't get what
Freedom they don't know what Liberty is
and that is really the beautiful part
about this video is these people truly
are scared of the things that they do
and the reason why is because they don't
understand that if you have a right it
extends to everyone else yeah like if
you have that we all get it right that's
the whole point of this country is
equality Equity Liberty it's almost like
those those words were written in like
some sort of like very old document uh
like a like a almost like a parchment
paper uh it
that established could it be Foundation
it starts with the c I believe could it
be called a constum
patience constipation I don't know maybe
there's something no no that no that's
that's what Herschel was oh you know you
know what yeah you know what it is it's
the thing they always they always talk
about all the time and they carry their
Bible and their constitution but they
haven't read either one of them right
the pocket ones right yeah let's let's
watch the Cockroaches scatter here this
is fantastic
foreign
why would these people need [ __ ] guns
I don't Somebody explain why you need to
have a [ __ ] gun on your hip if you're
just watching and the goal is for you to
call in something if you see something
illegal for whatever reason
why would you ever they're trying to
protect themselves from all their
enemies I guess I don't know but here
you see them leaving
now my assumption is and this lady makes
the same assumption uh here in the video
here just in a second that they still
have their plates covered up
and you would think that law enforcement
wouldn't let them drive off with their
uh their plates covered up because
they're trying to conceal their
their identity
the watch as they pull away
are people allowed to cover their plates
when they drive I'm pretty sure that's
in violation of multiple Arizona
statutes that's okay with you guys
what he said was is this isn't a public
roadway it is a parking lot now that
would mean that they would have to stop
at the edge of the parking lot before
they pull out in the street and get the
the yeah which I know they're not gonna
oh well absolutely they're not going to
do that and I'm sure the police will hop
in their cars and pursue them
immediately because they just admitted
that this is a public this is not a a
street so they don't have the other
place you would think you would think
let's watch I bet they climb in their
cars and do that let's watch
no it is and it's still covered
the police don't care because there's
something because you would think
they're they're exactly like you would
think did you hear what she said she
said the police don't care because
they're exactly like them oh wow because
really honestly it probably is true that
these police officers are mad at this
lady for doing what she's doing more
than they're mad at the people who are
sitting there with guns trying to
intimidate people not to drop a ballot
in the Dropbox right and really that's
probably the case here and you also see
in this white car another woman filming
um uh the the the the the the uh the the
hero here in this story
um she's trying to film and take
pictures of her watch watch as she takes
a few pictures and then scurries away
foreign
lady rolls down her window
decides to try to take pictures of the
lady you see her
as if as if
she's like oh well
I'm gonna get you like this lady's
probably thinking you can't kill me you
can't film me
and she scurries away like the Cockroach
that she is
um the beautiful part about this video
is this lady did more for our country in
just the few minutes that she was there
than the police did the entire time so
yeah
um it's kind of sad but I just want to
pull up this uh what do you get Miss
love speed or Miss loveseek says uh if
you do if you do witness intimidation
happening you can call 866 our vote
um to report it yeah I know that you
know it is the you know election
protection
um when it comes to your you know this
is a hotline where you can call in
report those things you know get tips
advice what have you
um so there are people out there
protecting our democracy from people
right right and and are going to seek um
any means necessary that they can to
make sure that if these people are doing
voter intimidation that they're held in
to account for it which it seems kind of
funny here and then this lady also
posted these pictures and the reason why
this seems funny is because
here is the same guy at the Arizona
capitol in August crying that Mar-A-Lago
was raided by the FBI so here is the
same guy
um crying now this is news to share I
don't know this I don't know what uh but
this is the same guy with the Rival you
know more you know what's better than
one look there look there what is that
it's that same looks like it's body cam
his cheap ass five dollar body cam you
know what's better uh than one American
flag on your shoulder pad six of them
two well the more you have because you
got more he's got your hand one on the
head right and he's got one in each
shoulder right which probably seemed
like that would be kind of the you know
I'm not I don't know the uh the proper
way to have a uniform I've never been in
the military but I I'm gonna assume that
just uh thrown on a couple American flag
uh patches are not the way that uh that
makes you patriotic okay I guess more
American flat automatically thrown on
your your costume makes you more like a
patriot the more the more American flag
50 cents American flag patches you can
afford the more you are a patriot
everyone who who is in the Q Anon
Network knows that
um here's again here's a shot now I
don't know if this is the same yeah but
he's got the he's got the light
adjusting glasses
good for him the transition lenses so
this is this is a Donald Trump militia
member now he is the sh he is the shark
army if I have ever seen it yeah you
guys know I refer to them here as The
Shard Army so hopefully the gazpacho
police right
hopefully we will get this Patriot on
our broadcast tomorrow
um we can ask her a few questions about
how she came to take these videos and um
I want to thank her for her bravery and
for her patriotism to actually uh get
these cockroaches to scatter and show
them show the them what they're actually
doing because I believe that's it did
you see you have some more breaking news
and then we just said no I just had
those two things oh yeah okay okay I
mean I'm I'm I'm relying on the breaking
news from our audience as they uh
justice oh go ahead I was gonna say I
just want to give a big thank you to the
people in the chat who are always
keeping us up to date with stuff whether
it's good news or bad news obviously
reported here on the show but it is
great to have you guys uh every audience
in the world because we can't you know
we can't do both things at at the same
time so it is good to get a heads up on
something I can barely read I can barely
react let alone talk and read this is
ridiculous what do you expect of me yeah
so so there is going to be um a press
conference supposedly eight minutes
which will probably start in like 20
minutes yeah right so I'm keeping an eye
on that if everyone would keep an eye on
it too so we can go to that I've got the
Department of Justice Feed up that's
where I'm I'm watching
um I don't know if um but it doesn't
look like they've opened up the feed yet
so no but we we will try to keep an eye
on that now Gabe this is very
um weird this morning that the
Department of Justice is coming out and
doing this this wasn't announced before
this morning a lot of people were
confused because it says a nation-state
actor
um a lot of people were confused by what
that means that means a country right so
like
um Saudi Arabia Russia you know where
I'm hearing I'm seeing that he is live
right now he is live okay let's let's
see if I can
uh I don't know I mean maybe but
Let me refresh it's a feed live or is he
up uh well this is here's the feed if
anyone wants a day we'll pull up the
feet here yeah I'll get that on the
screen here we go
so here is the here it is here's the
Department of Justice website
um and it it's showing Brett's Caverns
but I'm not seeing the uh the feed
um as C-SPAN mate no they are not even
showing the V let me go to let me see if
I can find it here
yeah it doesn't look like they're live
yet
um they have they have the uh links out
there and stuff right um and if you
stick with us here we'll watch it right
here on the Department of Justice
website the the broadcast that they're
gonna send out that's where we're gonna
watch it you also probably watch it on
C-Span they're going to show that
coverage on Siege span from a different
camera
um and you'll probably be able to watch
it on any other news organization at
this point because they really I don't
think they know what they're gonna say
have they said any more than it's just a
a news about a nation-state actor I
would imagine has to do with the
election in Russia is um that's my guess
I'm just guessing I uh I I I don't know
I mean who knows right some people are
saying it's going to be about Trump or
you know I I have no idea I I don't
think it's well I mean as much as it's
about Trump is that except Putin's uh
Putin's uh you know trying to interfere
in our elections to try to prop up Trump
candidates and trumpism but I mean uh I
know I don't think it's going to be
about Trump specifically yeah I don't I
don't think so I don't think that's what
we're looking at here maybe maybe uh
yeah I don't know but we gotta we're
about six minutes away from it being
scheduled
so let's do this let's go to a break
real quick
um see if I can smoke out exactly where
we're going to watch this from I think
we're going to watch it from the
Department of Justice and see when this
thing's gonna start it gives us a minute
to see if there's any other news
um and read about this if there's any
other breaking news because they will
start to release press releases
um moments before this press conference
I'm sure so there'll be people tweeting
about it so let's let's do this let's
take a quick break see if we can find
out some more information about this
everyone stick around we'll be right
back with the line coverage of the doj
press conference right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
trying to find out if there's any more
information on this press conference
um it doesn't look like we're getting
much more word about what this press
conference is going to be yet I was
checking uh Kyle Chaney's and Hugo's
Twitter page I know Gabe is that that's
who I usually go to when we're looking
for breaking news out of Washington DC
yeah it's either uh Kyle uh Hugo or
um Scott well yeah yeah Scott yeah Scott
Scott's Great especially if you're
looking for
um Department Justice and court cases
for the Insurrection Scott is a great
place to go Scott McFarland
um he's with he's with CBS now or am I
wrong is it the ABC I know CBS with CBS
yeah um and then Kyle is actually a
senior uh a senior legal Affairs
reporter for Politico
um and he's always on top of all these
score cases and Kyle really does a
nationwide coverage all right so you
keep track of that and Hugo's I don't
know is there like three of them or
something does he have like I don't well
he's with the Guardians he's with the
guardian but it feels like there's like
three of him too and I don't know I
don't know Scott's gotta have like oh
well Scott I've seen it I've seen a full
photo of Scott like presenting in front
of the camera and he's got like those
athletic like athletic uh like dress
shoes so I I don't know maybe he's
running from Courthouse
he doesn't walk he runs right exactly
right he doesn't walk he runs like he he
doesn't walk in I think you know just a
million dollar man just like running you
know as soon as he like as soon as he
gets out of bed he runs to the bathroom
rushes yeah he runs to the shower I
think so I think he like gets out of bed
he's already dressed he's got the suit
tie boom ready to go there's no way he
gets this month's information and he
knows everything yeah like I don't know
how the guy he keeps track of all this
[ __ ] like he he'll he'll go to like a
court case for uh or or a court
appearance for one of these
insurrectionists and he's got like the
video they're in he knows who they are
where they're from I mean he's again all
the news article Vehicles he's got their
rest seats right on all these on all
these people
um so it's uh it's kind of it's kind of
fun to to watch them be able to report
this like this from Twitter but that is
normally our sources that we look to
um when we're trying to find some
breaking news those are the beat
reporters
um and that's really what media needs to
get back to is beat reporters and we
need we need more beat reporting because
this stuff is getting a little crazy
when we have the media just capitulating
to just absolute outright lies it's it's
really [ __ ] frustrating
um when they do this here is a clip of
Kerry Lake now oh wow what the hell okay
let's see let me go back here and and it
did just to give everyone an update
right now uh yes the the you there is a
feed to the doj announcement but they
are not at the podium there's some guy
that's at the podium but he's in casual
civilian clothes so he's probably
checking Mike yeah he's is checking he's
just talking it's all muted so he's just
talking to uh the reporters right now so
and again there's nothing he's probably
doing mic checks and that's right right
we will we will go to it when it's on
but right now are you you're paying
attention to the Future yeah yeah are
you watching C-SPAN are you watching doj
I'm watching the doj feed I'm watching
uh the doj okay
um so here is here's a clip I wanted to
show you in the media trying to hold
Carrie Lake to account for her lies in
real time let's watch this you said
something last week you said that there
were 740
000 ballots with no chain of custody
those ballots shouldn't have been
counted are you really saying you would
throw out the ballots of 740
000 no three quarters of a million
arizonans I mean those were 740 000
ballots violated chain of custody
requirements in Maricopa County I mean
first of all it's it's not true I mean
Maricopa County Florida supervisors put
out a 98 page report that is validated
okay so he's trying to do a good job of
fact checking her in real time which I
commend him for but the problem is is
he's saying it's not true that that's
not what he should be saying what you're
saying is is a lie you're in because
saying something is not true is given
the assumption that Kerry Lake somehow
believes it
she is [ __ ] lying she's lying just
like the uh Fox News was lying about
dominion and Dominion now in this 60
Minutes interview I don't know if people
have caught clips of that but the
Dominion officials are saying hey and
the CEO is saying hey we sent them we
sent them information telling them that
they were lying to make sure they knew
that they were lying because at first
you got to believe well maybe maybe just
maybe this person believes this because
of other misinformation that they have
like Kerry Lake maybe believes in the
misinformation that she's beginning
folks we are almost two years
past the 2020 election there has been
not a [ __ ] shred not a shred of
evidence that there was voter I mean
other than in The Villages in Florida
where they were double voting for Donald
Trump right that is the only shred of
fraud that we've [ __ ] seen not a
[ __ ] shred of evidence not in Trump
courts where the Trump judges were not
at the Supreme Court not at these courts
these State levels not even with the
attorney general at the time Who was
appointed by Donald Trump who was his
[ __ ] Lackey Bill bar
okay not a goddamn shred of it
and for Kerry Lake to lie she is lying
to arizonans she's not she's not
telling untruths or not knowing what the
truth is she's [ __ ] lying and that's
how the media should approach this they
should come at him full force not white
glove it and be like Oh I'm sorry you
know I don't want to I don't want to get
you dirty and all that and say that
you're telling a lie she's lying it is
intentional it is malicious and frankly
there might be criminal consequences
especially if she had anything to do
with the state electors in Arizona but
let's watch that is a fact check your
thoughts we took that claim to Maricopa
County officials who refuted Lake and
pointed to the statement they issued
back in May saying that the county
always had control of the ballots adding
they quote were sealed in envelopes and
secured in boxes that bipartisan
couriers are prohibited from opening
okay so let me play that statement okay
and again this is ABC News and they're
doing a decent job here but not full-on
force that they could right this
statement from Maricopa County in May of
this year said that the ballots were
sealed in envelopes and secured in boxes
that bipartisan couriers are prohibited
from opening now this is their stupid
[ __ ] claim is that ballots were moved
from location to location
Gabe they literally are making two
arguments about [ __ ] in boxes all at the
same time okay they're saying if ballots
are moved from one location to another
location to be counted that's fraud
but if you take classified documents
that the federal government says do not
move these out of this room do not move
these yeah and you move them out of that
room well that's completely legal that's
completely everyone's done that and when
you move boxes from Florida to Trump
Tower or to Bedminster that's completely
legal listen folks here is the [ __ ]
thing those boxes are boxes that are
sealed they have a [ __ ] seal on them
from the one location to the next how do
they think these ballots get to
locations to be counted did they think
Donald Trump just thinks it and they are
this is [ __ ] absolutely the stupidest
[ __ ] I've ever heard in my [ __ ] this
is just as dumb or dumber than the whole
we have to watch a very secure ballot
Dropbox because there might be fraud
when they're not watching Post Office
boxes they're not watching People's
mailboxes that aren't locked that aren't
secure that don't have cameras on them
this is really stupid ass [ __ ] it
doesn't I mean like dumb as dog [ __ ]
well I'm I mean
it is on par for the Republican party it
is on par for Maga to to make these
claims not have any evidence right
Marjorie Taylor green said during her
debate
she goes we have the evidence there was
fraud my husband has it like okay first
off I don't know why your husband still
has it after two years she has a husband
I thought she's soon to be I guess
husband but what I will say is like when
you hear stuff like that it doesn't make
any sense because they are the dumbest
[ __ ] I've ever heard they lie
about coven they lie about human rights
they lie about
um your constitutional rights they lie
about voting you know there are all
these things in which they will say oh
you know what this only applies to me
right it doesn't apply to you it applies
to me and they've done it over and over
again it's a group that is literally
compiled with the largest sample size of
Dunning Krueger like in effect these
people
have a lack of empathy a lack of
intelligence a lack of self-awareness a
lack of comprehension just everything is
lacking from this group right and they
lack the proper votes to actually hold
people in office legally because 81
million people said you know I think you
said earlier in the show you know 81
people said talking to Trump you can go
[ __ ] yourself
but in this moment you have to look at
this and say it doesn't make any sense
and if there was actually evidence
especially under Bill Barr which was
Trump's A.G you think they would have
found something but Trump or Bill Barr
said that's [ __ ] right he said it
it's complete nonsense it's made up
there's nothing of of Merit that's there
so you said the words [ __ ] like yeah
he said literally [ __ ] he goes so I
told him that's that's [ __ ] right
and you look across the board and you
still have people who are election
deniers you've got people that were in
Arizona and Nevada two weeks ago who
were saying things like oh if you elect
me then I will be the one who decides
where and how this election is
determined for the outcome you had this
past Trump rally in in uh in in Texas
and Trump is saying oh well I'm going to
imprison any journalists who come
forward and actually do their job right
and he's I'm gonna and then he you know
make some
uh disgusting rape joke at the expense
of those who are actually exercising
their journalistic first amendment for
like rights
that is what these people are trying to
do they're trying to say no no no no no
this thing that actually was fair wasn't
fair
and even when you have dominion who's
like hey uh what you're saying is false
we have records of it we told you you
know it you acknowledge it and then you
continue to say that it was fraud we
have record of that and and since then I
don't know if they've made changes but I
can assume that maybe they made some
security changes which means that it was
it is already now even more secure for
this upcoming 2022 midterm election
because these people want to claim these
crazy conspiracy theories
they're they're gonna like they're
they're hoping that it fails they're
hoping that their actions
by committing fraud proves that there's
fraud
and that's what the Republican party is
trying to do right now they're trying to
swing the election in their favor by
cheating
but they say that the only way to fight
the cheating is to show out in Mass
numbers and vote so basically what
they're arguing is
elections or democracy works when a lot
of people vote well they're admitting
that they don't like democracy when it
doesn't go their way which is very right
because it gets less and less every year
I mean when's the last time you can
remember a republican being voted by the
popular vote
um here is here is the scene that we're
see this is the C-SPAN feed and they
have it up live right now they're
waiting the officials from the
Department of Justice to join them in
the press conference where of course
we're nine minutes over it looks like
which is not surprising I think you said
you'd we'd be about 20 minutes over
which is probably about correct
um so why we're waiting I want to remind
everyone that to go make sure to
subscribe if you're not already
subscribed to the YouTube channel here
at the Tony Michaels podcast uh super
important also go to our Twitter account
at Tony Michaels pod follow us there we
do the bone end of the week poll every
single week on the YouTube and the
Twitter account so you don't want to
miss that but download every single
episode too uh you gotta get the audio
version Gabe Spotify Google and why
you're there subscribing to our on
whatever favorite directory that you're
subscribing on to our podcast make sure
make sure that you leave us a great
review and if you're on Facebook right
now and I know you are there's a ton of
people on Facebook watching right now go
over to at the Tony Michaels go to our
page follow our page yeah I've been
putting a lot of means over there
um some other clips and videos
um so don't don't miss all the stuff all
the funny stuff you know you know me I
put the memes with the cursing on it and
put the swear words up there so if you
like swear word uh antifa pro-democracy
memes go the Deep State and teepa
pro-democracy memes and go follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels don't
forget the vowels there and also a lot
of people like the twitch chat did you
notice that I mean that's why they go to
it because it's a little different over
there Everyone likes the YouTube chat
but their twitch chat's a little
different some people dig that so if you
if you like the twitch chat go try it
out if you haven't already download the
app we don't get anything if you
download the app it's free and then you
can go watch the Tony Michael's uh
podcast over there on Twitch and also
don't forget it's it's getting cold
outside in a lot of areas in the country
game and people are gonna have to stand
outside to vote because I know you're
going to line up and keep lining up and
to pile on mountains of votes on these
fascists so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com and grab your
Liberty hoodies sweaters
uh jackets we got zip up hoodies there I
think we're gonna I think I'm gonna put
the fascism sucks design on this store
on store not doneymichaels.com we'll get
some um fascism sucks hoodies up there
so you guys can and also get you grab me
a t-shirt too and go to
store.donymichaels.com get your favorite
pro democracy
merch there we run on their support Gabe
this is the best audience in the entire
world and I do mean the world because
people listen to us all around the world
even haters listen to us around the
world but we run on your support rather
you share the show uh you buy some merch
you come here and watch live you watch
on the replay you give us a like a
follow put a comment down below even if
you're saying um weird stupid stuff to
us
the the trolls always help the
algorithms so we run on your support you
can also go to tonymichaels.live That's
Tony Michaels dot live and give us a
one-time tip or a monthly tip because
again it's Independent Media and we run
on your support it is you that we run on
and your support that gives us the power
to do this every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific while we're waiting Gabe I was
actually on a podcast
um over the weekend called the rational
Boomer podcast have you heard of this
show the rational Boomer podcast I think
I've heard a little bit about it yeah
Mike he's a tick tocker
um and I've known him for a long time
through Tick Tock well I I remember back
when we were just little ones on the
Ticky talk I think I had I don't know a
couple thousand followers he did too we
followed each other we
um we communicated even outside the amp
at that point but he has a podcast
called the rational Boomer podcast I was
on there over the weekend and man you
guys should really go check this out and
and it's on all the directories so you
can go to Apple Spotify
um you can even go to Anchor
um wherever you get your podcast and
just type in the rational Boomer podcast
the rational Boomer podcast and boy
um he gives great Insight he does he
does several shows a week he talks about
all the upcoming news sounds familiar
really to me
um but uh it's just an audio there's no
video so it's just an audio so if you'd
like to listen listen to podcast make
sure to go follow the rational Boomer
and take a listen to the interview that
he did with me over the weekend
um if I find the link here while we're
while we're waiting I'll I'll um I'll
post it up I actually posted on my
my Twitter page maybe that's the best
place to find it but just again go go
check out the rational Boomer podcast
another pro-democracy speech out there
working hard to try to get the word out
of about pro-democracy and find people
who are also pro-democracy you know get
us talking to each other get us leaning
in get us really making sure that we're
working hard to save our democracy so go
to the rational Boomer podcast wherever
you download your podcast check it out I
know he's on Apple Spotify and anchor
now here it is here it is let's see I'll
retweet it there and see if I can grab
the let's see if I can grab the link
here dude there it is okay I'm gonna put
the link in the chat here copy this is
the uh the episode that I was on and
paste there we go the rational Boomer
podcast oh and look at that art look at
our great moderators boom Margie already
with the link
the greatest moderators on Earth we have
the greatest audience on Earth and we
have the greatest moderators on Earth I
don't know if I don't know if the
audience knows that so give the give the
uh the moderators some love there in the
chat I think I think Margie's with us
today and Robin we got three moderators
that way they can switch off and if they
got some busy things they got to do but
um MJ's also I don't know if MJ's in the
chat today I think she was busy so but
um thank the moderators for being in the
chat and uh being here every day to help
keep the chat going and we love having
the engagement we we've got like one of
the highest engaged chats that I've ever
seen Gabe did you know that yeah I mean
our audience I I think you know even
with uh even with the trolls you know
there's a lot of Engagement that's in
here and I think it's it gives people a
place to
you know it's [ __ ] crazy out there
guys uh we've got a lot at stake in a
matter of like two weeks and
um I think this this allows people to
kind of have a a cathartic release on
everything that's going on to stay up to
date but also meet and talk to people
you know to tell Ted Cruz to go [ __ ]
himself
um but also find other people
like-minded people who are pro-democracy
and chat with them and communicate and
just feel like you're not alone in this
[ __ ] of a wannabe fascist state
right
um so I think that's important I think
Community is important and I know that
against people themselves the [ __ ] em
fam yeah absolutely well I think that's
that's what pro-democracy people should
be doing is creating uh communities
everywhere tight-knit communities small
communities big communities
um but we really should be working hard
to to find each other and really
motivate each other because I think
that's the one thing the media is doing
wrong
and I don't know if they're trying to
scare people to vote
um because I do have a bone to pick oh
really let's go ahead and I think I
think it's what you're going to talk
about are you going to talk about this
kind of like defeatist attitude yeah
yeah they're not yeah yeah it's you know
it's it's almost as bad as the both side
[ __ ] right right I mean here's the thing
regardless of what the outcome is right
you don't tell someone
straight up and go well it doesn't look
like it's gonna be going our way based
on these polls if we've learned anything
anything for the last two years of how
polling is done right and also
especially in the last this the the
primaries right you had New York and
Kansas you're seeing signs that would
show and indicate that the polls aren't
going to be correct right
um
you have to go to the polls
with the idea that nothing is certain
there is no guarantee you can't go there
assuming well looks like he's got a 10
point lead so we're just going to vote
for him or we don't have to vote or
whatever it might be you have to assume
that everything is at stake because it
is if you don't vote
then then that is you know one of those
situations where you can't come back and
be like oh well I gotta complain about
this well if you didn't actually
participate and vote like everyone
should right and everyone has the right
to no one should be denied that right no
one should be intimidated to not
exercise that right everyone should be
able to exercise that right to vote and
and support and promote and fight for a
free and safe election for a democracy
that is in our you know our United
States of America right what our country
was was formed on and no one should be
able to take that away no one should be
able to take any of the rights away that
you have been given as citizens of this
country but that is what Republicans
want to do that is what Trump is is that
trumpism that's with fascism that's the
Republican party as it is right now so
vote vote vote like there is no tomorrow
right you gotta vote
even if even if you think oh it's a done
deal it's a blue State it's a blue
County whatever still [ __ ] vote
that's right we got to show them that
we're out and and we're about and we
ain't gonna lay down right here's a
here's a clip of Grandpa Poopypants oh
my god dude he needs to lay off the Q
Anon like just lay off of it for a day
or two man just he's just he's doing
like some Adderall take some Adderall
and lay off the Q Anon my friend Jesus
Christ let's let's listen to
hell there's Q Anon words out listen to
this I I it's seven seconds but it's
it's uh a big pile of [ __ ] so prisons
are being emptied out from many many
countries not just three or four that
are closed many many countries they're
being emptied out into our country
what did he just say did he just say
because this is the [ __ ] that you're
gonna vote for if you don't go vote for
pro-democracy candidates is this crazy
ass queuing on nonsense he's saying I
think he's saying that countries are
emptying their prisons and they're
dumping them here like I don't know like
out of an airplane I don't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about I mean maybe
he's like whoop see you later I don't
know like I don't know what the lottery
how is
I mean I know it's probably got some
sort of racist you know string to it
he's like other countries what he really
means like anyone who's you know is oh
my gosh
anyone who is not white obviously he's
gonna be like oh this is uh you know
it's [ __ ] dumb and it's crazy it is
insane to think that we have a previous
president like if you want to consider
him a president but a previous president
a former president that is now going
holding these rallies obviously grifting
you know his supporters into uh paying
for the repairs of his I think it was
like around six million dollars to
repair his uh Trump farce one I mean a
trump Force One yeah that was a story
over the weekend that the media also
bought her behind Sinker and and you
know it's just it's just one of those
things where this guy is [ __ ] insane
but he's saying the things whether he
whether he is uh uh actually believing
in it or not I don't know but there's a
lot of confirmation bias in terms of him
hearing the things that he wants to hear
from the people right like you watch the
rally in Texas all right we're at 21
minutes yeah you're getting close you
were close you were close I I don't
expect this to last long when they come
out right yeah I mean like I mean if
it's like the last one he came in like
when when that guy came in with the nail
gun and wanted to throw this is post the
Mar-A-Lago uh League one and like uh
Detroit or some [ __ ] when they shoot no
it's Ohio right well yeah or was it
troyed I forget which one I don't know I
don't know they get all kind of mixed
around with these after the guy came in
with the nail gun and was like I'm
coming in guns blazing for Trump because
the FBI legally searched Mar-A-Lago
because Trump illegally stole classified
documents we have learned last week they
contained secrets about China and Iran
so you know for anyone out there who's
like those are his he owned them those
are his property uh no they're [ __ ]
not those are secure classified uh
sensitive materials that should not be
outside of a skiff should not be outside
of a secure location it should not be
something that uh Trump can just show
off to his golf buddies or whoever's
[ __ ] simp and form in that office
that
when he so basically Garland did that
after the guy came in shooting with the
the nail gun and he was pissed he was
like dude
that's a nail gun does a nail gun make
that sound pew pew I mean I think no I
think I mean I know what it actually I
know what the actual sound but I think
when a nails
so I would say that this probably isn't
very long I mean considering how long
the other one was that he did when the
guy came into the FBI building obviously
this was a response to be like look well
on the one he did on the documents I
mean you remember right right and he was
like look I signed off on this thing we
had evidence we're doing our job do not
villainize the FBI agents who are there
doing their job
and he was like I'm not gonna comment on
the rest of it because I don't have any
more to talk about thank you goodbye and
like that is looks so now yeah so now
like uh it looks like there's some
movement nope I thought maybe there were
some um it looks like they're going to
be coming up the ramp here and is where
they're coming from you see the security
standing in the background there and
we're waiting we're waiting for the doj
officials Merrick Garland Christopher
Ray and the um I think the deputy
attorney general is going to be joining
them I think maybe a few others the last
one was just it it was just Merrick
Garland so yeah the fact that it's the
three of them is right I think it's
interesting well and again the news is
uh let's go check on Twitter and see if
and I'm obviously not the biggest fan of
Ray I I call them out in the most recent
what was that that I did on the Jan six
day nine recap right because Christopher
Ray let's remind ourselves right the guy
has said at least twice in front of the
Judiciary Committee the Senate Judiciary
Committee uh we had no intelligence we
had nothing that we could act on in
terms of January 6th when we've seen
electronic community locations from the
FBI to the Secret Service saying hey
there's qrfs qrfs in Virginia and this
is what the Oath Keepers are saying and
then you also have to remember that uh
Christopher Ray is the guy who ignored
the 4500 tips about Kavanaugh and sent
him over to uh
to to Bill Barr and Donald Trump I think
someone's going to come up in a moment
and talk
are they there's a delay here yeah it
looks yep it looks like um there they
are yeah I've got a little latency on my
side here they come in
um so let's um let me turn the volume on
good afternoon this is your two minute
warning
attorney general Merrick Garland Deputy
attorney general Lisa Monaco FBI
director Christopher Ray an assistant
attorney general for National Security
Matthew Olson will deliver remarks
also here in the stage will be Assistant
Attorney General for the eastern
district of New York Alexander Solomon
as well as Assistant Attorney General
uh assistant to U.S attorney for the
District of New Jersey granted can we
turn it up thank you yeah I'm trying to
do my volume booster but it's not really
helping much all right so it looks like
it'll be 30 minutes past
let's start yeah so um where that was
the two minute warning so we got two
minutes so we'll keep our eyes on that
um while we go
um Gabe tell us about Trump farce one
real quick
um yeah why why why the media is dumb
about this while we're waiting well uh
as we know Trump uh has grifted his
party and his uh his cult into giving
him money this thing has been hanging
out in a hangar for years and needed
repairs Trump said hey look guys you
want to help me out uh refinance her
home and give me money so I can repair
my plane which I think it was like about
six million dollars in repairs and now
you know he's flying around it typically
makes short trips you know to 757 I
think is what it is
um but the issue that a lot of people
have is all right this guy just prepared
this plane like are we not like
literally literally could get on a
flight so is this the same plane though
that like kind of broke down and they
took to Texas right I I don't know if it
was to Texas
oh yo sorry he did just take it to Texas
for this route that's what it was yeah
but it was repaired somewhere down south
because they right right they had
trouble getting it there it was right so
it's been hanging out it was a pile of
[ __ ] yeah and I'm sure it's still a
piece of [ __ ] joke
there's literally a uh a tour video that
I've I don't know who the woman is but
she gives a tour video years ago when
they talk about like oh here's the
um
here's the bathroom the gold plated this
this and this here's the seats the
executive here we're gonna have we're
gonna have the Attorney General here
hang on one second all right with
Optimum not the ad
uh
oh
let me damn it
oh yeah he's up oh [ __ ] five of them six
of them
you know
as always the defendants in these cases
are presumed innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law
earlier today in the eastern district of
New York a complaint was unsealed
charging two PRC Intelligence Officers
with attempting to obstruct influence
and impede a criminal prosecution of a
prc-based telecommunications company
the complaint alleges that in 2019 the
defendants directed an employee at a U.S
government law enforcement agency to
steal confidential information about the
United States criminal prosecution of
the company
the defendants believed that they had
recruited the U.S employee as an asset
but in fact the individual they
recruited was actually a double agent
working on behalf of the FBI
as the complaint alleges the defendants
paid a bribe to the Double Agent to
obtain non-public information including
files from the U.S attorney's Office in
the eastern district
so in the hope of obtaining the
prosecution's strategy memo confidential
information regarding Witnesses trial
evidence and potential new charges to be
brought against the company
the double agent provided the defendants
with documents that appeared to present
some of the information they sought
in fact the documents were prepared by
the US government for the purpose of
this investigation and did not reveal
actual meetings Communications or
strategies
this was an egregious attempt by PRC
Intelligence Officers to Shield a
prc-based company from accountability
and to undermine the Integrity of our
judicial system
Also earlier today in the district of
New Jersey an indictment was upsealed
charging four individuals including
three PRC Intelligence Officers with
conspiring to act in the United States
as illegal agents on behalf of a foreign
government
the indictment alleges that between 2008
and 2018 the defendants used the cover
of a purported Chinese academic
Institute to Target co-opt and direct
individuals in the United States to
further the prc's intelligence mission
those directors included attempts to
procure technology and equipment from
the United States and to have it shipped
to China
they also included attempts to stop
protected First Amendment activities
protests here in the United States which
would have been embarrassing to the
Chinese government
separately
in the eastern district of New York the
justice department charged seven
individuals who are working on behalf of
the PRC with engaging in a multi-year
campaign of threats and harassment to
force a U.S resident to return to China
last Thursday we arrested two of those
defendants
those activities were part of the prc's
global extra legal effort known as
operation Fox Hunt
its purpose is to locate and bring back
to China alleged fugitives who have fled
to foreign countries
including the United States
the PRC has a history of targeting
political dissidents and critics of the
government who have sought relief and
refuge in other countries
the indictment alleges that the
defendants working at the direction of
the government of the PRC
engaged in a campaign of harassment
threats surveillance and intimidation
aimed at coercing the victim to return
to China
we also allege that the defendants
threatened and harassed the victim's
family members both in the U.S and in
China
the PRC government forced the victim's
nephew to travel from China to the
United States to convey the prc's
threats to the victim's son
the defendants threatened the victim
saying that quote coming back and
turning herself in is the only way out
they showed up at the home of the
victim's son in New York they filed
frivolous lawsuits against the victim
and his son and said it would be quote
endless misery for the defendant and son
to defend themselves
and they made clear that their
harassment would not stop until the
victim returned to China
as these cases demonstrate the
government of China sought to interfere
with the rights and freedoms of
individuals in the United States and to
undermine our judicial system that
protects those rights
they did not succeed
the justice department will not tolerate
attempts by any foreign power to
undermine the rule of law upon which our
democracy is based
we will continue to fiercely protect the
rights guaranteed to everyone in our
country and we will defend the Integrity
of our institutions
before I turn the podium over to Deputy
attorney general Monaco I want to
recognize the FBI the National Security
Division and the U.S attorney's offices
for their extraordinary work on these
cases
now Deputy attorney general Monaco
thank you Mr Attorney General
Justice will not tolerate threats from a
foreign power to the rights of Americans
or to our nation's institutions
as the attorney general has laid out the
case is unsealed today take place
against a backdrop of malign activity
from the People's Republic of China that
includes Espionage harassment
obstruction of our justice system and
unceasing efforts to steal sensitive U.S
technology
in the words of our intelligence
Community China seeks to be a major
power on the world stage and to
challenge the United States in multiple
arenas
today's cases make clear that Chinese
Chinese agents will not hesitate to
break the law and to violate
International Norms in the process
two of those cases in particular show
the lengths they are willing to go in
pursuit of unfair advantage
but the defendant's charged today met
their match in the agents analysts and
prosecutors of the Department of Justice
according to one indictment unsealed
today two Intelligence Officers
attempted through bribery and Espionage
to obstruct the Federal Criminal
prosecution of a global
telecommunications company headquartered
in the PRC
the defendants attempted to bribe
someone they believed was an Insider to
steal the prosecutor's Playbook
including who the prosecutors were
meeting with and what they would argue
in court
all so that the company could unlawfully
gain an edge and undermine the
government's case
but The Insider flipped the script on
the defendants by working not for them
but for Team America
the defendant's desperate efforts to
sabotage this prosecution expose the
prc's government's commitment to tilting
the playing field in favor of Chinese
corporations abroad
far from accepting the rule of law PRC
agents sought to use bribes to help the
Chinese company obstruct and evade it
this case exposes the interconnection
between PRC Intelligence Officers and
Chinese companies and it demonstrates
once again why such companies especially
in the Telecommunications industry
shouldn't be trusted to securely handle
our sensitive personal data and
Communications
in another matter announced today
individuals associated with the Chinese
government allegedly continued its
Relentless campaign to gain access to
our technology recruit agents and
attempt to stifle the free exchange of
ideas according to the indictment over a
10-year period the defendants and others
used a fake Think Tank to try to recruit
a formal former federal law enforcement
and state Homeland Security official and
others through a variety of means
including with all expense paid trips to
China
in each case though the plots failed
because the men and women of the
Department of Justice defended our
institutions and thwarted the persistent
threat posed by agents of the PRC
I want to thank the agents analysts and
prosecutors in all three of these cases
for their tireless work on behalf of the
American people
and now I'll turn the podium over to FBI
director Ray
well thank you first let me Begin by
pointing out the 10 of the 13 charged
individuals we're discussing today are
Chinese Intelligence Officers and
Chinese government officials they're
charged in three different cases that
might seem at first glance to be about
unrelated issues however
and this is something that I've been
talking about for years now each of
these cases lays bare the Chinese
government's flagrant violation of
international laws as they work to
project their authoritarian view around
the world including within our own
borders
in all three of these cases and frankly
in thousands of others we've found the
Chinese government threatening
established Democratic norms and the
rule of law as they work to undermine
U.S Economic Security and fundamental
human rights including those of
Americans
we also see a coordinated effort across
the Chinese government to lie cheat and
steal their way into unfairly dominating
entire technology sectors putting
competing U.S companies out of business
as I've pointed out before their
economic assault and their rights
violations are part of the same problem
they both flout the rule of law
and one of the purposes of the Chinese
government's repression is to make it
easier to steal our innovation
they try to silence anyone who fights
back against their theft companies
politicians individuals just as they try
to silence anyone who fights back
against their other aggressions
and in our cases today we've got yet
another example their attempted
obstruction of an independent judicial
process to give underhanded help to one
of their companies accused of breaking
our intellectual property laws and deny
Justice to that company's victims
since I started as FBI director I've
been repeatedly sounding the alarm about
the Chinese government's disregard for
fair business practices for
international norms and for the rule of
law
the FBI has been reaching out and
warning and more importantly helping the
communities the Chinese government
targets businesses of every size and in
almost every sector from agriculture to
Green Tech to semiconductors
the chinese-american community
Academia and state and local governments
and our foreign Partners around the
world
today
every one of those Partners is awake and
alert to that threat in a way that just
wasn't always true five years ago
and our success bringing more and more
Partners to this fight highlights
something else important
Beijing may think our adherence to the
rule of law is a weakness
but they're wrong
we're disrupting Chinese government
criminality and aggression not just
while adhering to our values but by
adhering to our values
aren't Democratic and legal processes
arm us with weapons that China doesn't
have among others real partners and
allies and our Partnerships help protect
the American people
every day
today's cases are no different we
couldn't have accomplished this work
without our foreign partners and the U.S
academic community in particular
one reason we've had so much success
bringing Partners to this fight against
the Chinese government's aggression is
that they see through beijing's
hypocrisy
for example they see the type of CCP
hypocrisy on display in our Fox Hunt
case today yet another case where the
Chinese government officials and
co-conspirators mercilessly harassed a
naturalized U.S citizen to try to force
him to return to China against his will
they accused the victim in this case of
embezzling money but two of the subjects
who targeted him
to the defendants charged today
are themselves actually involved in a
scheme to launder millions of dollars
and as if that weren't enough evidence
that the real purpose of their operation
was political
they gave their victim a deadline to
return by
the 20th CCP Congress earlier this month
they're focused on repression
not law enforcement
but our partners also see the ccp's
broader hypocrisy the fact that while
the CCP claims to stand for sovereignty
and non-interference in other states
Affairs what the Chinese government
actually does
is interfere with Sovereign governments
around the world whenever doing so suits
Beijing
here interfering with our independent
judiciary
violating both our sovereignty and the
Norms of police conduct to run Lawless
intimidation campaigns here
in our backyard and corrupting our
academic freedom to further their
campaign of repression and Theft
the FBI is going to continue to say what
we mean and mean what we say so our
partners both here and abroad many of
whom tell us they're battling Chinese
aggression themselves no they can depend
on us against the Chinese government and
countless other dangers
finally let me urge any person or
company being targeted or approached by
the Chinese government to come to the
FBI for help no American citizen
resident company or university should
battle this threat alone
and you don't have to you can report
information through your local FBI field
office or online at fbi.gov
and know that our Coral is with the
Chinese government the Chinese Communist
party not the Chinese people and
certainly not Chinese Americans
I want to congratulate all the FBI
special agents intelligence analysts and
professional staff who have worked on
these cases as well as our partners at
CBP and the IRS
I also want to take the opportunity to
specifically thank the government
employee who played such a critical role
in the obstruction of justice case you
know we employ double agents frequently
in our counterintelligence operations
against the PRC services and other
foreign threats
and given the nature of that work we
very rarely get a chance to publicly
thank them so I am delighted to have
that chance today
thank you
good afternoon
these three cases highlight once again
the threat that individuals acting at
the direction of the PRC government pose
to our institutions and to the rights of
people inside the United States
these operations include the harassment
and attempted repatriation by force of
individuals living in the United States
the effort to corrupt our judicial
system and the attempt to recruit agents
for the PRC under the cover of a phony
academic organization
we will not tolerate these actions the
National Security division which I'm
privileged to lead was created to take
on our most significant National
Security threats these cases reflect the
breadth and the Persistence of hostile
nation-state activity
these actions threaten our sovereignty
and they threaten the rule of law and
countering these threats is a
Cornerstone of the mission of the
National Security division
our success in disrupting these threats
depends on our strong Partnerships with
the U.S attorney's offices with the FBI
and with the U.S intelligence community
so I want to take this opportunity to
recognize the exemplary work of the U.S
attorney's offices that made these cases
possible
first the U.S attorney's office for the
eastern district of New York that's led
by Brienne peace and I want to thank
assistant U.S attorney Alex Solomon who
is with me here on stage ausa's Meredith
arfa and Antoinette Rangel as well as
National Security division trial
attorney Scott claffey I also want to
recognize Philip Sellinger the U.S
attorney for the District of New Jersey
we are grateful for the work of
assistant U.S attorneys Brendan day who
is also here in Joyce malliet
along with the FBI and the National
Security division these offices and the
attorneys in these offices are on the
front lines every day working to defend
our national security and to deliver
Justice on behalf of the American people
thank you
we got everybody okay in that case we're
ready for some questions
um I was hoping one of you maybe the FBI
director could talk a little bit about
um
okay I'm actually gonna stop with the
questions
um because we are way over time here and
I want Gabe to kind of explain
um while that we're playing this on mute
what you made of the um the actual press
conference here was much longer than we
thought because they had several people
speaking
um but um a lot of people at first was
like PRC what the hell is that that
sounds like uh something weird that's
the uh people's
um Republic of China
um so it's China when they're saying PRC
yeah so the I mean you could read more
about this on the the doj website uh
eastern district of New York that talks
about this there's also an earlier case
that took place in that they referred to
in 2022 and 2019 basically in these
documents you're going to see stuff that
call that talks about company one right
they're not going to talk about who it
is in these documents but it's Huawei
it's a it's a Chinese in uh
Communications comp telecommunications
giant okay so basically a
the what's it called again Wow way is
that what Huawei it's
h-u-a-w-e-i
okay they're not actually naming it in
the indictments they're just yeah they
call it company one they name they name
the the two individuals from the PRC uh
who are working on behalf of Beijing to
obtain prosecution Secrets by bribing a
person that they did not realize
was a US double agent okay so
and this is why we have this is why we
have double agents by the way right so
for this exact reason for people who
don't understand that he this he or she
this agent pretended to be someone that
was going to subvert uh the U.S
democracy and Injustice system by
providing them Secrets but really they
were actually so they were pretending to
be bad but really they were good so
that's where this double agent comes
right so they were they were pretending
to work for the PRC when in fact right
now we know because of today's press
conference they were actually working
with the United States right so uh this
goes back to
um the the doj indicting Huawei
Technologies back in 2019 and they were
accusing which by the way is one of the
world's largest Communications equipment
manufacturing and some of his Executives
of violating U.S sanctions on Iran or
Iran and conspiring to obstruct Justice
related to the investigation which
prompted Furious condemnations from both
the company and the country now the new
charges suggest that the Chinese
government went to incredible lengths to
defeat the U.S case against Huawei by
assigning U.S Intelligence Officers to
obtain information about Witnesses and
evidence so basically to get information
to Blackmail people threaten them we we
heard them talk about how a father and
son were threatened basically in their
involvement in this case
um so it's a there's a 29-page complaint
that's unsealed today that talks about
these two Chinese magnets I think it's
squash on hey and Zhang Wang and the
charges that they attempted to recruit a
person they believed to be a double A or
to to a U.S and law enforcement agent
employee who had decided to be a spy but
really was a double agent
um and basically what they did was they
shared these secret government documents
that they that they uh the FBI had
fabricated right so they made up these
documents to make it seem like they
wanted yeah they want to try to get a
fake feedback loop right they want right
they want to spit something in it and
see what comes out there exactly and so
they they of course bit but if you look
at this complaint you know some people
have described it as like a spy novel
and the way that it really describes
like how you know to use a public phone
to connect a person they had connections
with in the Justice Department offering
bribes and Bitcoin you know people were
assigned code names uh there's money
laundering obstruction all of this stuff
in terms of uh subverting an
investigation or or uh taking away from
investigation against Huawei uh
Technologies for this case that have
been brought against them so that's I
mean there's a lot more details in this
um this uh this 29-page complaint that
was unsealed today that you can go read
about online
um but that is basically what it breaks
down to this company one that they're
talking about is Huawei and its
investigation that was targeting Chinese
spies and this alleged double agent U.S
spy
um and that's what this is all about
um basically the Chinese government
using a uh working with
a Communications company to
get out of this investigation right find
stuff that they could use against
someone to say hey we should drop this
case because I'm being blackmailed to
threatened or whatever but really the US
knew what was happening
they put people undercover as a double
agent
gave them bait to to take and they did
the these PRC these agents um for the
Chinese government and then getting the
information they needed to actually uh
round out a full case of them trying to
obstruct Justice launder money threaten
people's lives like again it reads like
a spy novel it's pretty crazy but
um well you know I think I think this
means politically is that um you know
because that's what that's that's what
we kind of do here is break down what
politically this means really honestly
this tears apart the Republicans ability
to sit and Yammer on about how Joe Biden
is soft on China and he's with China
China when in fact his Department of
Justice is uh leving uh big huge
indictments here and this isn't just
indictments of these individuals it's
you heard mayor Garland speak it is an
indictment against the the PRC he said
we will not tolerate foreign actors I'm
intimidating people in our country and
breaking their civil rights here in our
country
um we we will not tolerate that so I
think I think more than anything this
sends a message out that Merrick Garland
is not scared of China even so uh this
this narrative now a lot of people were
expecting this to be about Trump I
didn't actually think this was going to
be about Trump this morning when they
said
uh nation state actor I figured Russia
China maybe something about the election
but this is something totally unrelated
from that other than it is it is a
foreign actor an authoritarian power as
Christopher Ray put it authoritarian
power trying to subvert our [ __ ]
Constitution and our sovereignty as a
nation and our sovereignty to our
citizens and the people who are here who
were afforded Liberty rather you're a
citizen or not whether you're a citizen
or not you are afforded those Liberties
wow you're here I think that's the most
important thing
um we did go over time today we wanted
to show you that press conference sorry
we did not get to all the questioning
maybe we'll cover some of the questions
tomorrow if there's some news made in
those questions I want to give you
explaining he messaged me said hey I can
explain this so I wanted to explain
before we left
um everyone don't forget to subscribe to
the YouTube channel it's super important
you don't want to miss a thing here on
the Tony Michaels podcast so go over to
YouTube subscribe right now also um
while you're at it why you're on the
interwebs make sure you're you're
following us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod we will have the bone of the week
pole as we do every week on the YouTube
and the um Twitter Channel also download
every single episode on Apple Spotify
Google make sure while you're there
subscribing you leave us a great review
on your favorite directory and if you're
on Facebook right now make sure you go
follow us there at Tony Michaels we I
put up a lot of these these memes and
they got curse words in them so if you
like if you like the political means
with swear words in them you're going to
like to follow on Facebook and Instagram
I wish I always forget that yeah
Facebook and then the same thing though
everywhere and kind of I mean you know
you're not on Facebook but you're on
Instagram right no I uh I love Facebook
you know it's just I left it you guys
broke up huh we me and Mark we were
tight well you are on Facebook you're
just not you just don't have a page on
Facebook yeah I'm done I mean you're
there every single weekday Monday
through Friday right yeah through there
right of course they're broadcasting
live every day on Facebook you're just
you just broke up with Facebook yeah
it's it's officially like if we were to
be like what's your relationship status
broken up but you live in like the same
apartment building right yeah yeah I
mean like marketing each other every
once in a while
on this stream right yeah so that's how
that's how it works I'm on video I'm not
on Facebook with the profile
everybody don't miss a single episode
this week as you should every single day
every weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and simulcasting from
Facebook the Midas touch Facebook page
and our Facebook page don't miss a thing
tomorrow Texas Paul is in DC and no one
knows this so I'm trying to see if we
can do like a on the ground type thing
we can get him in the Oval Office we'll
get Biden in yeah he'll be like well I
know they're laying it out they're
hanging out they're hanging out all
right so maybe maybe we'll have Texas
fall tomorrow I hope I can convince him
audience to be here for at least a few
minutes yeah yeah Tuesday everyone knows
is Texas Paul and taco Tuesday uh Gabe
it's our favorite day of the week Texas
Paul Tuesday and tax Tech Taco Tuesday
so don't same time same place tomorrow
on Tuesday don't miss it until then
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
it's fun in your face commentary of
current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass speaking